[Music]
images of a new Russian base at the top
of the world this morning are fueling
concerns about new tensions in the
Arctic the outpost is part of an
expanding Russian military presence in
the region the area is rich in oil and
gas reserves the complex is located in
desolate area at the edge of the Arctic
Circle
Jonathan Vigliotti is in London with how
Russia is racing to secure untapped
resources Jonathan good morning good
morning with Arctic sea ice melting
thanks to rising temperatures once
frozen ocean is now open for business
legally it's still unclear who can lace
take to the territory but the Kremlin
knows how persuasive a good show of
force can be President Putin has never
been one to pass up a photo-op
and his latest candids come from the icy
Arctic photographed in March pensively
walking among glaciers the Kremlin has
also previously released video of
reindeer riding Russian soldiers all of
this part of the unveiling of the
country's crown jewel Russia's sprawling
trefoil military base located just
outside the Arctic Circle can house 150
troops and warplanes while parts of the
base remain top-secret the military
offered up a virtual tour of the
interior of the building this PR rollout
comes as Moscow moves to lay claim to
the region's huge oil and gas reserves
believed to be worth as much as 35
trillion dollars Russia the US Canada
Denmark and Norway have all been trying
to assert jurisdiction over parts of the
Arctic Robert English is a former
Defense Department policy analyst we all
stand to make money in the Arctic but of
course this will all grind to a halt if
we see a new arms race instead while the
US has a military presence in the Arctic
including airfields and infantry bases
there is concern in Washington that
Russia has pushed in recent years to
expand its own military capabilities
there its most significant buildup in
the region since the end of the Cold War
I think Secretary of Defense James
mattis address
the issue during his confirmation
hearings what do you think Russia is
trying to achieve in the Arctic with
that massive military buildup I don't
know I believe however that we are going
to have to figure it out for now
Russia's flag seems to be firmly planted
on the top of the world and some US
senators have already called on the
Trump administration to grow its
presence in the Arctic including
building more ice breaking ships Russia
is believed to have 40 of the vessels
the u.s. Noora only has two Jonathan
great reporting I'm glad we did this
this is a future Battlefront is
certainly the Ark that's exactly what it
is yeah did the conflict with Russia is
now global every part of the earth
including the top and the bottom okay
yeah it's just interesting to see
Russian riding reindeer I mean what do
you say what do you say
reindeer riding Russians I thought that
was an interesting image right
you always think about horseback cavalry
not reindeer or Santa our Sam